devil fruits are the embodiment of
people's dreams that grow on the
treasure tree adam on love tale in other
words devil fruits the treasures of the
sea are part of the one piece
at least that's going to be my current
answer to the question what devil fruits
are and where they originally come from
yes there is still a lot we don't know
about these magical fruits that give
people incredible powers but there also
is quite a trail of breadcrumbs for us
to follow throughout the story as well
the most basic observation i can make
when i look at a devil fruit like the
miramira know me is that this is a plant
a pretty extraordinary plant that will
turn my body into fire yes but
nonetheless plants it's a bad tasting
fruit with a stem that didn't just pop
into existence but that had to grow
somewhere
i think the smile factory on dressrosa
that is actually full of important clues
is a great example for this now as you
know it seems like devil fruits can
reincarnate in a suitable fruit close to
where the previous user died as we saw
with caesar's pet smiley and probably
when blackbeard took whitebeard's fruit
as well but these two are people who
know way more about how these fruits
work than most and don't forget that
they must have come from somewhere in
the first place so there must be some
original source for them what's up my
name is manu and even though i really
don't have a green thumb when it comes
to keeping plants alive why do i still
believe that this should be a tree and
not i don't know a devil fruit ranch
where you grow all types of devil fruits
in different ways well first of all in
romans dawn the one shot that was the
blueprint for one piece luffy's fruit
was explicitly stated to have grown on a
tree but also because trees are one of
the most important symbols in one piece
similar to how whales represent love
tale as i discussed in my last video we
have the sun tree eve the treasure tree
atom the tree of knowledge on o'hara the
whale trionzo and the sacred trees on
both shondura and in wano that are
believed to hold the souls of their
ancestors
[Music]
now what do you think do all these trees
have in common but how does this bring
us to the devil fruit tree on love tale
and oh what's that huh a sponsor well
that's convenience as you can see this
video is sponsored by hong kai impact
third hong kong back third is a free to
play anime style action role playing
game for both mobile and pc in the game
you control a team of up to three
characters known as valkyries in a
real-time combat system against various
enemies the new version 5.5 brings new
character displays the most awesome
probably being to randall who not only
is the first to get a black and white
form but also a new battle suit display
as well as new outfits for all the
characters and since right now they're
celebrating their global server's fourth
anniversary there are a ton of event
bonuses and gifts you get a special
fourth anniversary emblem a variety of
upgraded materials 37 supply cards and
over 4 000 crystals the spring event
also includes a new s-rank battle suit
and if you download the game now you can
redeem the gift code here on screen
right now for 30 crystals
2888 asteroids and a hasha trial card so
make sure to check it out yep trees in
one piece represent the void century and
the ancient kingdom eve is connected to
both marijua and fishman island with
poseidon and joyboy's apology o'hara was
studying a poneglyph and the true
history of the worlds both shondura and
wano were closely connected to or maybe
even part of the ancient kingdom itself
by the way you also have the giant jack
on skypia that holds the golden bell as
well as this weird giant tree on mono
that is the center of the capital
[Music]
and we also have a number of trees that
literally hold souls this tree on
thriller bark as well as king bound and
the entire forest on whole cake islands
again close to a road ponentliff the
whale tree on zou is even more special
because it combines both symbols the
tree and the whale in other words zou is
connected to the ancient kingdom and
gives direction to love tale and there
is actually another really important
tree in one piece this one right here
[Music]
so what does drum island out of all
places have to do with anything well
plants in one piece are closely
connected to one specific group of
characters doctors and this goes for
devil fruits as well chopper is seen
using herbs to make medicine and drugs
the mushroom that poison hero look
cherry blossoms the herbs and medical
knowledge in torino kingdom dog q and
his explosive apples crocus being named
after the flower on his head law who
wouldn't be able to do any advanced
surgery like cutting drugs out of the
kids without eating his devil fruit and
belladonna on amazon lily being named
after the flower atropa belladonna which
is a medical plant as well
then there's also noland who cures the
shandorans with his chestnut heads and
of course the master of them all dr
vegapunk and so drum island is a very
important link here in many ways for one
there's the image of the giant cherry
blossom tree yes but drum island is
especially famous for its doctors
which got me wondering
why yes chopper and kureha are great
doctors no question about it but what
makes this country stand out from other
doctors like law or the island that
chopper went to to train on during a
time skip well at least on the surface
there are two real oddities on drum
island that make it special from a
medical perspective dr corey has long
lifespan as well as chopper's rumble
balls
the rumble balls are especially
interesting to me because they seem to
unlock the hidden potential in chopper's
devil fruit and did this young reindeer
who was studying under a quack really
come up with such an advanced technology
all by himself or could there be some
hidden knowledge on drum island about
the real nature of devil fruits i also
don't think it's a coincidence that
blackbeard went there because anything
he does is planned out really neatly
also remember that chopper himself is
connected to trees as well
[Music]
now let's address the elephant in the
room why are there three big trees in
the one piece world that all have an
obvious biblical theme we have two trees
called adam and eve both of whom lived
in paradise
in this garden called eden there were
two special trees the tree of life that
grants immortality as well as the
forbidden tree of knowledge just like
the tree of knowledge on o'hara and so
eve was tempted by a snake to eat an
apple from the tree of knowledge the
forbidden fruit for which her and adam
were made mortal and cast out of heaven
and this snake is often seen as the
embodiment of the devil and now it's of
course pure coincidence that the people
of o'hara were called devils by the
world government for their research
oh yeah and i almost forgot we're
talking about literal devil fruits here
now as you know whenever hola sensei
takes inspiration for his story he never
copies anything one to one but gives
things an interesting twist the story of
adam and eve in christianity judaism and
islam represents the original sin of
humanity being seduced by the devil and
eating the forbidden fruit in one piece
on the other hand the people of ohara
like robin clearly are portrayed as good
people interested in the truth and just
painted as devils by the government and
so i think it's clear that in the world
of one piece the government in other
words emu the gorosei and the other
celestial dragons represent god only
that here god is the bad guy the tree of
knowledge on o'hara would then represent
the sin quote-unquote of gaining the
same knowledge as the government and how
they came into power as i've discussed
in detail in this video here there is a
good chance that the life tree that
grants immortality is the sun tree eve
that seems to be located inside the red
line reaching up towards marijuana it
might very well be this tree that gives
literal immortality to the celestial
dragons that live in quote unquote
paradise on top of the red line by the
way as you know marijua is located
exactly where the red line crosses the
grand line dividing the world into four
oceans and even though i'm not very
religious i found there was this line
from genesis that reads a river watering
the garden float from eden from there it
was separated into four headwaters
another very interesting reoccurring
theme here that i completely overlooked
at first is that of the forbidden fruit
being an apple the fruit of the devil
being an apple this pops up quite a lot
throughout the story you have dog q's
apples the smile fruits all being apples
smiley's devil fruit reincarnating into
an apple anal the god eating an apple
and so on and so forth there's
definitely some sort of pattern here
so now the only aspect of the garden
eaton reference that has no clear role
yet in the story is the treasure tree
adam the story goes that god made eve
from a part of adam which would then
suggest that the sun tree eve was made
from the treasure tree atom as well a
connection that by the way usopp also
seems to make
as frankie explains to us once long long
ago an endless war raged on a certain
island people died and the island was
destroyed by a rain of bullets and left
in ruins however the people kept coming
back to rebuild their nation near a
giant tree the only tree that remained
intact and that tree was adam now not
only does that suspiciously sound like
the ancient kingdom to me but there is
also the idea of rebirth not unlike the
devil fruits themselves so could the
treasure tree adam be the original devil
fruit tree that grows on love tale i
think a big hint here is its name the
treasure tree treasure makes me think
immediately of the one piece not only
that but devil fruits are called the
treasures of the sea and when you really
think about it treasure and trees are a
theme in the story as well
[Music]
nami's treasure is buried under belmer's
tangerine trees the library on o'hara is
under the tree as well the road
ponoglyph is under the whale tree you
get my point also as i've discussed in
these videos i believe that love tale
was the left eye of jaya that was then
swallowed by a giant whale and is now at
the bottom of the sea the other city on
jaya shandora also had this giant
sapling growing at least until the straw
had cut it down and if love tail was at
the bottom of the sea that would explain
why it's called the treasure of the sea
and the fruits of the devil after all
the ancient kingdom would have been the
devil to the gods of the world
government just like the people of
o'hara and so these fruits now could
float to the surface and then spread
throughout the world now at the
beginning of all this i mentioned that
devil fruits are literally the
incarnations of people's dreams so what
do i mean by that well this idea is part
of euderon's mega theory about one piece
that once again keeps blowing my mind
every time i hear something new about it
the bases for this idea are roger's last
words
[Music]
you have inherited will that is first
introduced by dr kureha back on drum
island call back i already talked about
the possibility that devil fruits might
actually inherit part of the previous
user's will to whoever eats it we have
people's dreams and the passing of the
ages that means that people's dreams are
inherited throughout the ages and never
die this idea is confirmed by none other
than blackbeard himself who is not only
an absolute devil fruit nerd but also
seems to be the only person who knows
how to consume multiple fruits
[Music]
this man's most important statement is
that people's dreams never ends i think
haki plays a role here as well because
we know that people can manifest their
wills into reality in this world we also
know that souls are not only real in one
piece but that they are said to enter
trees in the cultures of wano and
shandora that are both closely connected
to the ancient kingdom chapter 225
titled people's dreams where blackbeard
makes his famous speech has hachi on the
cover page dreaming under a tree of
making takoyaki on a deserted island
like the deserted island love tale and
in general i don't think i have to tell
you that dreams is one of the most
fundamental concepts in the entire story
and so all the big trees in one piece
are collecting something the tree of
knowledge on o'hara collects wisdom the
suntree eve collects the sunlight the
trees on shandora collect souls and so i
believe that the treasure tree adam
collects people's dreams the dream to be
a bird the dream to be fire itself or
the dream to turn everything into a toy
all these abilities are just so
fantastical and things that can only
come from people's imagination and oda
sensei might have made this a quite
literal part of his story this would
also explain why there are only zone
smile devil fruits yes you can take the
lineage factor from an animal and try to
merge it with a human but you can't make
an artificial logia or paramecia fruit
now this possibility absolutely blew my
mind but it gets so so much crazier when
you look at the big picture the idea
that love tail and the devil fruit tree
are at the bottom of the sea is part of
a much much larger theory that puzzles
together the biggest mysteries of the
series and that's why you really
shouldn't ignore this video because
it'll make you question everything you
thought you knew about one p